>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Rob Casper: Joy Harjo and A.B.
Spellman could not be better suited
to be up here with me today.
Both are claimed poets but both are
also uniquely connected to music.
Joy Harjo performed for many years
with her band, Poetic Justice,
and currently tours
with Aerodynamics.
She has 5 CDs of music and poetry
including her most recent award
winning album of traditional fruit,
Red Dreams, A Trail Beyond Tears
and Winding Through the Milky Way,
which won the Native
American music award
for best female artist
of the year in 2009.
Harjo currently has a commission
from the Public Theatre of New York
to write, We Were There When
Jazz Was Invented, a musical play
that will restore southeastern
natives
to the American story
of blues and jazz.
Speaking of jazz A.B. Spellman
is an expert in the form.
He published his first book
of poems, The Beautiful Days,
in 1964 by working as
a jazz music reviewer.
In addition to writing reviews,
essays and poetry for Metronome,
Down Beat and Rhythm Magazine,
he published Four Lives
in the Bepop Business in 1966.
In 1975, Spellman became director of
the Arts in Education Study Project
for the National Endowment for the
Arts where he worked until 2005.
His service to the organization is
honored by the A.B. Spellman Award
for Jazz Advocacy bestowed
upon an individual
who has contributed significantly
to the appreciation, knowledge
and advancement of
the art form of jazz.
Before we begin with the
readings and the performances
and then our conversation, I want
to give us just a little
bit of context.
In the excellent reference
book of Poet's Glossary,
Edward Hirsch writes, "Song was
originally inseparable from poetry.
They were one in the same and
poems were meant to be chanted
and sung sustained
by oral tradition."
Poetry is still considered
song in many parts
of the world whether
it is presented with
or without musical accompaniment.
The musical element is
so intrinsic to poetry
that one never forgets its origin
in musical expression in singing,
chanting and recitation
to musical accompaniment.
With that in mind please join me
in welcoming Joy Harjo
and A.B. Spellman.
[ Applause ]
>> Joy Harjo: [Inaudible] It's good
to be here and especially to get
to present with A.B. Spellman,
who is one of the major ancestors
of poetry jazz and so on.
I also want to acknowledge
Michael Harper, poet,
whose poetry also led
me to poetry and jazz.
I'm just going to start
with a piece called,
We Were There When
Jazz Was Invented.
I'm a member of the Mvskoke
Creek Nation from Oklahoma.
Our people were moved from
the southeast from Alabama.
The Mvskoke homelands were all over
the southeast, Florida, Georgia,
Alabama, Tennessee
over into Mississippi,
and the Mvskokian peoples were even
all the way through the southeast,
and we were part of the origin
story of blues and jazz.
We're often left out of the story.
We're often left out of the story of
American music, of American history.
We've been essentially
disappeared from the narrative.
And yet, when you go to our
ceremonial grounds, our dances,
you can hear, you hear
it, there it is.
And if you think of the origin
of jazz being Congo Square,
where the African Peoples
came, got free on Sundays,
Congo Square was a Mvskokian
tribal village and there it is.
So, we were part of that story.
This poem is for Jim Pepper
Henry, one of the first,
and I just lost my read somewhere.
Thank you.
Jim Pepper Henry, a Mvskoke
Kaw, musician, played jazz
and he was playing standards and
working rock, mixing rock and jazz
and his band was one of the first
to do a fusion with beginnings.
He was also part one of the
people who began the world jazz.
He helped, one of the
originators of world music.
Anyway I wrote this poem
as a tribute to him and one
of his most famous songs is
Wichiti Tai To from the song
that his grandfather taught him.
So here I'll read the poem
and it's called We Were There
When Jazz Was Invented
because I'm working on a story
to include Native peoples, our
Native peoples in an origin story.
Okay, Wichiti Tai To.
[ Music ]
[ Speaking Native language ]
I have lived 19,404 midnights, some
of them in the quaver of fish dreams
and some without any memory at
all, just the flash of the jump
from a night rainbow, to an island
of fire and flowers-such a holy leap
between forgetting and jazz.
How long has it been
since I called you back?
After Albuquerque with my
baby in diapers on my hip;
it was a difficult birth, I
was just past girlhood slammed
into motherhood.
What a bear.
Beyond the door of my tongue
is a rail and I'm leaning
over to watch bears catch
salmon in their teeth.
That realm isn't anywhere
near Los Angeles.
If I dream it all back then I
reconstruct that song buried
in the muscle of urgency.
I'm bereft in the lost
nation of debtors.
Wey yo hey, wey yo hey yah hey.
Pepper jumped and some of us
went with him to the stomp.
All night, beyond midnight,
back up into the sky, holy.
[ Music ]
It was a holy mess, wholly
of our folly, drawn of ashes
around the hole of our undoing.
Back there the ceremonial fire
was disassembled, broken and bare
like chordal breaks
forgetting to blossom.
Around midnight, I turn my back
and watch prayers take
root beneath the moon.
Not that dreams have anything
to do with it exactly.
I get jumpy in the aftermath
of a disturbed music.
I carried that baby up the
river giving birth to nothing
but the blues in buckskin and silk.
Get back, I said, and what
bird have you chosen to follow
in your final years of solitude?
Go ahead, jump holy
said the bear prophet.
Wey ya hah.
All the way down to the
jamming flowers and potholes.
There has to be a saxophone
somewhere,
some notes bear little
resemblance to the grown child.
Now I've got to be dreaming.
Take me back to Tulsa.
I'm too young to marry.
I can only marry the
music; the outlook's bleak
without it I mean and then I don't.
Too many questions mar the answer.
Breath is the one and two and
dream sweet prophet of sound,
dream Mvskoke acrobat of disruption.
It's nearing midnight and something
holy is always coming around.
Take love for instance, and the bare
perfect neck of a woman who's given
up everything for the forbidden
leap to your arms as you lean
over the railing to
hear the music hopping
at the jump pull of the line.
She will never be here
again in the break
of the phrase back before this
maverick music was invented.
It's the midnight hour and
sweet dark love bares it all.
I can hear it again;
the blue moon caving
in to tears of muscle and blood.
Birth of the new day begins
less than one second after.
It's that exact, this
science of the holy.
So that's where it is, this
incubation of broken dreams.
It took forever for that
bear of a horn player
to negotiate the impossible jump.
Weh yo hey Weh yo hah, those
water spirits will carry
that girl all the way back to the
stomp grounds where jazz was born.
It's midnight.
How holy.
[ Music ]
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> A.B. Spellman: That was gorgeous.
This first poem is about aging.
Something that happens to
all of us and I am in the,
I'm in my middle aging
period I hope.
[Laughter] We're asked to read
poems that integrated music and,
music and poetry and this poem
actually is more about music
as metaphor and so not much
to tell you about it except
that the weird words in the
second stanza are technical terms
of the drum.
I did not make them up.
It's called Groovin' Low.
Any hipsters in the room
will recognize this as a play
on the title of a Dizzy Gillespie
tune called Groovin' High.
Whatever Dizzy was talking about
I'm talking about getting older.
[Laughter] My swing is
more mellow these days:
not the hard bop drive I used to
roll but more of a cool foxtrot.
My eyes still close when the rhythm
locks; I've learned to boogie
with my feet on the floor.
I'm still movin', still
groovin' still fallin' in love.
I bop to the bass line now.
The trap set paradiddles ratamacues
and flames that used to spin me
in place still set me off, but
I bop to the bass line now.
I enter the tune from the bottom up
and let trumpet and
sax wheel above me.
So don't look for me in the
treble, don't look for me
in the fly staccato splatter
of the hot young horn.
No, you'll find me in the
nuance hanging out in inflection
and slur I'm the one executing the
half-bent dip to the slow slowdrag
with the smug little smile
and the really cool shades.
[ Applause ]
This poem is a little dense.
All right.
I won't interpret it for you.
Between the night and
its shadow is the music.
Between the music and
the night is the song.
Between the song and
the music is the voice.
Between the voice and
the music is the self.
Between the self and
its song is the mind.
Between the mind and
the song is the melody.
Between the song and its
melody is the rhythm.
Between the rhythm and
the melody is the mind.
Between the mind and
its song is the word.
Between the word and
the mind is the voice.
Between the voice and
the word is the thought.
Between the thought and
the voice is the self.
Between the word and
the self is the shadow.
Between the shadow and
the self is the light.
Between the light and the word is
the music The song is the melody
in the word in the rhythm.
The self holds the mind to the
word and the thought of the song.
The voice in the song
sings the self to the mind.
The light lights the shadow
of the voice and its melody.
The rhythm moves the self
through the dimming night's song.
The thought in the song is of
night's shadow without music.
[ Applause ]
This poem I wrote in a
hotel room one night.
Hotel rooms are good
places to write poems.
It was in Boston I believe, and
I was listening to the radio
and on one station I heard some of
my favorite Johann Sebastian Bach.
It was the keyboard
concerto in f minor
and then another station later
I turned to another station
and heard John Coltrane
playing Trane Slow Blues.
The thing about these two poets,
these two musicians is that I
as a poet aspire to be good.
I think if I write enough poems
maybe I'll stumble on a couple
of great ones somewhere, but
with people like Sebastian Bach
and John Coltrane you deal with
something greater than good,
greater than great, you
deal with the sublime,
which I can't even aspire to.
I don't think that there are
five musicians on the planet
at any given time who achieve that
state where it gets to be about more
than music, more than beauty,
more than power, more than truth.
It's something where you feel
that you are absolutely changed
on levels that you cannot parce.
So, this poem.
Dear John Coltrane, dead
night has me writing poetry
in another hotel room.
J.S. Bach is on the radio, the
keyboard concerto in f minor,
the one you also hear
on oboe or violin.
The largo second movement behings
and the book in my hand drops,
the room fades, and I put my
reason down to trail the bach
of endless line along
this earthless path.
Each note full and bright, a
brilliant footprint on the dark,
through beauty, past knowledge and
into that state that shines too much
to be wisdom, is too
transparent to be art.
I catch a fear of the place
where he will lower me
when this transporting
melody closes.
Then it closes on itself, dear John,
and I'm back at the
beginning better.
Later different station,
cold room dimming,
it's you, John, Trane Slow Blues.
Now it's your line that
opens and opens and opens
and I'm flying that way again.
Same sky, different
moon, this midnight globe
that toned those now lost
blue rooms where things
like jazz float the mind.
This motion, the still and airless
propulsion I know as inner flight.
This view the one I cannot
set with my eyes open.
I hear the beginning approach
and I know the line I travel was a
horizon, the circle of the world.
Another freedom flight to
another starting place.
If I believed in heaven,
I would ask if you, J.C.,
and Bach ever swap infinite
fours and jam the sound
that light makes going and
coming and if you exchange maps
to those exclusive
clouds you travel through.
And do you give them names?
You asked for three
poems by other people?
All right.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Rob Casper: So we're just going
to take a second to get mic'd up
and then we'll have
our conversation.
All right.
Let's see.
Am I live?
Can you hear me?
Now can you hear me?
You can hear me, okay.
Thanks to you both for
contextualizing our conversation.
Your readings made for
very interesting contrasts
in how poetry can engage with
music and specifically jazz,
and it made me think of these two
quotes I pulled from both of you.
In an interview recently,
Mr. Spellman,
you said I'm still a
two-dimensional page poet at heart.
That would be interesting to
talk about that kind of realm
in relationship to music especially
when you're reading poems that are
so indebted to music as the theme.
By contrast, Joy, you
say for me music gets
into the places that
words can't touch.
When people ask me how do
you do both disciplines
by which you meant poetry and
song, I say I think of it as one
but it's almost like
having two lovers.
So, I thought we'd begin by just
talking about for you, you know,
in terms of forming content
in terms of this relationship
between these two, these two forms
of expression how you
negotiate that.
>> Joy Harjo: Okay.
I'm ready.
Yeah, I was, I'm thinking what you
said about a person of the book,
and when I first started writing
poetry, I always loved poetry
and I came to poetry through music.
My mother used to write
songs and a lot of ballads,
she loved Nat King Cole,
and she also often played
with country swing musicians in
Tulsa, but I came to my education
in poetry in the US
educational systems
and then later Indian boarding
school and poetry was in a book.
But then as I came
to being a poet, I,
and I'm a Mvskoke person I went
looking for my people's poetry
and found out I'm related
distantly to Alexander Posey,
a very well known Creek poet who was
writing and alive during the time
that blues and jazz, you know,
around the time of Buddy Bolding
and so on, and but then I also went
back to I think where is our poetry?
Most of our poetry, most of the
world's poetry, isn't in books.
It's part of, it's out of
reality, oral traditions.
So I went home, you know, home
to the ceremonial grounds too
and there is where I heard it's
this incredible song poetry.
A lot of it is announcement
and there's a form to it
and it's beautiful
and that inspired me.
Sometimes it's called
meko hadjeda [phonetic]
or in my pronunciation is horrible,
but it's usually announcing,
it's setting into place often poetry
does, you know, Coltrane is setting
into place a place where you can
actually can see, hear the divine,
you know, he's talking to God.
And so in what we're going to hear
we'll just play just not very much
of it, but you can hear Sherman
Franks who was very renowned
as a speaker who is calling,
talking about calling in leaders
from other ceremonial grounds
and talking to them about dances
and saying come in and sit down.
And then there's a whole, you
know, calling in different grounds.
So there's form, strict
form to all of this.
So I would like you to
play the first it's called,
I think it's the very
first one, the top one.
This is Sherman Franks.
We'll just play a little
of it so you can hear it.
No, the very first link.
It's called Stomp Dance.
I'm sorry.
What? It's the very first one.
Yeah, go ahead.
[ Speaking Native Language ]
Okay. Thank you.
So that's just a little bit of
that form, that oratorical form,
that to me is beautiful,
and I'm learning Mvskoke,
I don't know it well, but I
want to learn it well enough
so I can understand the form and
exactly how it's put together,
but it inspires me to hear that.
And that is one form of
Mvskoke poetry, yeah.
>> A.B. Spellman: Yeah,
I guess first of all there
are several factors involved
in my own inhibitions that
lead me on the page primarily,
and that has to do with the fact
that I didn't come to poetry
from the tradition as you did.
I came, I came to music
that way because I lived
in jazz my whole life and later
expanded my interest in music
as I left the south, but no,
it was, that was one world.
And then when I became
more literate in college
when I started being exposed to a
wider range of artists or writers,
then that commitment to the
page was sort of structured
into my reflexive system.
The poets that affected me
most in my formative years
in the 1950s were poets who were
very concerned with measure,
with [inaudible] were going to work
with whether the line broke
according to breath or according
to text and things like that.
And that really was
my formative period.
Now then when the movement began
among African Americans or got,
not when it began because it was
always there, but when it got to be
so prominent among African American
people in the civil rights movements
and the struggles for human
rights and the anti-war movements
and the movements of people
with specific cultures when all
of that developed, starting
developing in the 60s,
I was caught rather off guard.
And so I'm confronted with
things like meeting Malcolm X
and telling him I'm a poet and him
asking me, well, what does that have
to do with what we're doing
and me saying, well, not much.
[Laughter] And that hurt.
That hurt a great deal.
Now the younger poets
who came behind me,
the younger African American poets,
started from a different place
because by that time they were,
I mean I moved into the movement
as a form poet, but the younger
poets moved into the poetry
and the movement at the same time
and they took performance
very, very seriously.
They were faced with reaching
audiences that were not people
who sat in small rooms
and discussed, you know,
finite issues of aesthetics.
They were trying to relate to
something that was happening
in the world that was
greater than them,
and this was very difficult for me.
I never have been good
at writing topical poems.
I've tried I don't know how
many times to write a poem
about the killings on the streets of
young Black men and never been able
to succeed in pulling a poem off.
I could write a great essay on
it, and I've written pieces on it,
but I have never been
able to make a poem of it.
And that's an ambition of mine.
So, as goes to music, I have
moved in with musicians.
Musicians have found music in
my poems and set them to music.
And, in fact, I sent, I sent
a piece in do you have it?
It's called the Passion
for John Coltrane and Bach.
You don't have it?
>> No, sir.
>> A.B. Spellman: Okay.
So, the composer named Jeff
Scott has set several of my poems
to music, and I read it with
them and that works quite well.
It's a good piece that he wrote,
and I find myself now writing,
I've just completed Legretto
[phonetic] on the Great Migration
where I could write for singers and
for musicians, but as of a matter
of performing the way Joy
performs, I've read with Ann Halprin
in New York this spring and she's
working with her young nephew
who is an alto saxophonist.
She's writing a lot of
her pages are sounds.
I'm much, I'm just too
inhibited to do that.
>> Rob Casper: I do though
wonder what it's like,
what it was like to hear that
piece performed, you know,
what it was like to see
music attached to that piece.
And, Joy, I'm wondering when
you write a poem that is printed
in your new book, what is
it like to read that poem
as opposed to performing that poem?
Sort of the converse of what
I'm asking Mr. Spellman.
>> A.B. Spellman: Well, for me the
thing is I read with the musicians
and it's a piece for a wind quintet,
string quartet, jazz trio and me.
And it's a pleasure
because I actually listen,
I try to read into the music.
It's not background music.
I read into the composition
and it works quite well
and it gives a great
deal of satisfaction
and it's has had good response so.
>> Joy Harjo: Yeah, I started
out just reading my poems
and that one is the one I read.
I haven't started trying to sing
it and, but it's very different.
What I've discovered
is with Poetic Justice,
and I'm one of that
generation that I came
out of Native rights movements
part of the civil rights movements
and so I started writing poetry out
of response to what was going on.
I'm terrible at occasional poems.
I can't write on command either.
I can't do it.
I'm very, I can't do that, but
the poems, my poems started coming
out of the experience of young
Native women who weren't often,
you know, we weren't
necessarily the speakers
but we were experiencing
what was going on.
So one of mine for Anna Mae Pictou
Aquash, Whose Spirit is Present Here
and in the Dappled Stars
(for we remember the story
and must tell again so we
may all live) is a poem
for Anna Mae Pictou Aquash and that
was the first song that I wrote,
but I had the poem first and then
I started reading my poems to music
and working with a reggae artist
and then it moved into singing.
But then I found that when I started
writing poems to sing it's phrasing,
the lines are phrasing,
they're like a horn riff,
you know, they're phrasing.
And so that's how, you
know, it's all about rhythm.
I think everything
goes back to rhythm.
I think the world started
with rhythm.
The big bang, it was somebody,
you know, there you go.
It started with rhythm and so
that's, and so I started, you know,
I have to move to it, you
know, and it's on the page,
you move to it on the page too.
We all do, and I think when I
heard Linton Kwesi Johnson read
in the Netherlands
and I thought, whoa.
And then I heard Jayne Cortez
and I thought there it
is, you know, there it is.
It's, you know.
>> A.B. Spellman: I do think
that music does affect my poetry
because for one thing I
write with a lot of iambics.
This is not a conscious
decision this just,
it's something I discovered
about myself that is,
you know, there is rhythm.
The line has to swing, the
line has to scan and --
>> Rob Casper: -- swing and scan.
>> A.B. Spellman: It
has to, it has to do it.
Even if they're not set
metric values in there.
So, I think that's why this
proposal found the poems
to be worth writing a piece for.
>> Rob Casper: Yeah, yeah.
>> Joy Harjo: Isn't the I am
kind of a back beat anyway?
>> A.B. Spellman: Yeah, it is.
>> Joy Harjo: It is a back beat.
>> Rob Casper: So I just want to ask
one more question and then I'm going
to open it up for all
of you to ask questions,
which is this is different
cultural space music
and poetry operates right
now in America what you think
that might say about
either the power of either
or if it's just a sort of
artificial construction?
>> Joy Harjo: Sometimes I
think we're going back to that.
I've felt when I, you know, when
I, when I was at home and realized
that it's poetry, music
and dance are together
that I think naturally
they're together.
They don't like to be apart.
And I sometimes I see
watching culture evolve
from when I started writing in
the 70s to the kinds of poetry,
slam poetry and even images
but and watching how all
of that has evolved, I think
maybe that's where it's headed
or maybe that's where we've always
been on some level is that we're,
you know, they want to be together.
>> A.B. Spellman: It's true you see
it more and more and more by poets
who are extremely musical and
whose, even if they're not working
with instruments their own
presentation is more musical.
I think that, and also you've got
to realize things like the influence
of hip hop on younger
people [inaudible],
which also like bridges
this whole thing.
So, anyway so I think, I think that,
yeah, there are pockets where poets
and poetry consumers sit in small
rooms and deal in the old ways,
but then there are lots
of, there are larger spaces
which draw more people where music
and poetry do swing together.
>> Joy Harjo: But even then
it's important the impeccability
of the word is important.
>> A.B. Spellman: Yeah.
>> Joy Harjo: You know even with
performance that word is just
as important as the
impeccability of the music.
>> Rob Casper: Anybody
have any questions?
Can you just go up to the mic?
>> I'll kick it off.
>> Rob Casper: Thank you.
>> Hi, Joy.
It's really good to see you
again, and Mr. Spellman.
You were talking about poetry and
music I mean it's always been there.
If you go to the Greek tragedies,
you know, the choruses and,
you know, the poets in jazz
and hip hop and, you know,
that's what it's all about.
I wonder if both of you could
comment on the influence
that Black African American
poetry in music has affected you
in the Native spirit and vice
versa, if there's been any influence
of that in your production
or your writing?
Has there been any
cross pollination there.
>> Joy Harjo: Definitely.
I think it's in America.
I think it was there at Congo Square
when our people were, you know,
I can see the whole scene.
I mean it was, you know, I
think the African people then
like our tribes here
everybody knew their identity,
still had their tribal identities
and so I can see what went on.
It was a crossover too.
It didn't just go one way.
There is no one way land bridge
that Natives came across, you know.
It doesn't, a healthy system,
cultural, social, it goes like,
you know, it feeds each other.
And so for me I think
of it beginning there
but when I first started
writing poetry as a student
at the University of New
Mexico, I went I thought tribal.
Okay, who are the tribal
people writing?
I went over and started
looking at African poets
like Ocot Petit [phonetic] from
Uganda and I got to meet him,
but I started looking there to
looking for somebody contemporary
who was doing more poetry that
was probably closer related
to what I would think of as
Mvskoke poetry and then, of course,
a lot of the African,
African American poets,
June Jordan, there's just so many.
Ishmael Reed brought,
he helped start
that multicultural poetry movement.
He brought a lot of us to New York
City in the late 70s and that's
when I heard Jayne Cortez and
something in her, you know,
and we had a friendship
through the years
and it was like there, you know.
It opened up that door for me.
>> A.B. Spellman: Yeah, well music
and poetry has been
there in the beginning.
In fact, I've always thought
that prosody was an expression
of the root of music in poetry
that the poets needed a mnemonic
to be able to remember so they
had to develop forms to go with it
and these forms were shaped by song.
I've always thought
that's been the case,
but among African American poets
the concern has always been there.
Langston Hughes, for example, was
very much committed to having,
to finding a jazz voice in the
poem and several of his poems
like The Weary Blues and so
forth are attempts to do that.
He also worked early
with the musicians.
In 1958, he had a gig at
the Village Vanguard working
with Phineas Newborn who was the
greatest jazz pianist you never
heard of and Charles Mingus
which wouldn't you like to have
that with you on the stage?
And so that's always been there.
He also wrote with
Kurt Vile and so forth.
So, that's always been
an element of the music.
There's nothing new actually.
It all was an expression of
tendencies that have been in art
from the beginning and so people
like Jayne Cortez was the
first musician I knew who,
first poet I knew who
traveled with a band.
>> Joy Harjo: Yeah.
>> A.B. Spellman: And I
thought that was great.
Mary Beraca did some great work with
musicians specifically Craig Harris.
[Inaudible] who died much
too young was wonderful,
was powerful with musicians.
The difference is between this
work, the modern work and the work
of say the Beats was that you
would have when Robert Bly
or Kenneth Rexroth or those
guys were reading poems
with music they'd be at the stage
and be some guy plucking along
with them on the guitar, and
it would be like background.
It really wouldn't be
very much integrated.
The differences now is that it's
one thing, that it's one thing,
and that's where the power is.
>> Rob Casper: You
have another question?
>> Hi. First off I really
enjoyed this presentation,
and I have two questions
for you, Mr. Spellman.
My love for jazz brought
me into poetry
and you mentioned John Coltrane.
The first time I heard Coltrane is
like even now it's like having an
out of body experience, and I
wanted to know when you started
out what jazz musicians
influenced you, touched you deeply
to write and can you tell me why?
And one more other question the
Miles Davis movie with Don Cheadle.
I waited years to see
something like that.
I was so totally disappointed.
I just wanted to know, I just wanted
to know what did you think of it?
>> A.B. Spellman: Oh, man.
[Laughter] Well, frankly
they blew it.
There's some good things
in the movie.
>> Joy Harjo: Yeah.
>> A.B. Spellman: There's
some good things.
Don Cheadle did a great job,
but there are too many
compromises I think that had
to be made to get the movie made.
>> Joy Harjo: Yeah.
>> A.B. Spellman: What's
his name, the British actor?
Something [inaudible].
Anyway his role was completely
artificial through much,
much of the movie and
had nothing to do
with anything Miles Davis ever did.
That was a story, there's a lot of
stories to be told about Miles Davis
and they told just a
small fraction of it.
So, no, that was disappointing.
It's hard to single out musicians
who, jazz musicians who affected me
because I mean I was so,
it was a real pleasure
to be immersed completely in music
and lower Manhattan
during the 1960s.
That was a real, real pleasure
because the music was everywhere,
it was immediate, I knew the
musicians, and I could stop by,
I could stop by their pads in
the afternoon and we'd sit there
and then they'd show me what
they were working on now.
So that was, that was an immersion
that I wish everyone could have.
There aren't any more
scenes like that today.
So it's hard to single out people,
but Coltrane does stand out.
Coltrane does stand out because
Coltrane's commitment was total.
>> Joy Harjo: Yeah.
>> A.B. Spellman: It was a
total complete commitment.
Someone asked him what is
you want your music to do?
And he said I would like
to make people saints.
And that's what he set out to do.
He set out to change people.
And so it was, that's how I
got into writing about music
because I would go to hear Trane,
I would leave there
dripping wet feeling
like I had had my soul rinsed out
and then I'd read Down Beat magazine
and they'd say this is the worst
thing to happen to jazz ever.
>> Joy Harjo: Oh, geez.
>> A.B. Spellman: So I would
say either I can't hear
or these guys can't hear.
So, I started writing
in defense of it so.
>> Rob Casper: We were
lucky enough to hear
from both A.B. Spellman
and Joy Harjo today.
Thanks so much for
coming out and please go
to their book signings
and buy their books.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.